good evening turning a tragedy into an
extraordinary tribute
after gregson elementary school student
died suddenly at just
six years old her teacher joined her
family to create a very special
scholarship in her name
thanks for joining us i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftis in just a few years
they've already helped so many achieve
their dreams
sasha loftis first introduced us to
maria jose in 2019
she joins us live tonight with this
amazing update
yes denise and brian since maria jose's
family and friends have started this
scholarship fund
they've helped to change the lives of
countless students here
at gregson elementary former students of
gregson elementary and they tell me that
they're not done just yet
she had a big big heart for her age
three years ago
las vegas lost the light that was maria
jose
gonzalez vasquez she had a
long life left to live and it's just
hard that she had to go so soon the
six-year-old died suddenly
after contracting meningitis just months
later
her family and favorite teacher
channeled their unexpected grief
into an amazing gift to honor her life
and to keep her memory alive
because i want not only my children but
the students that i have that continue
to come to gregson to know about her
working with her former school they
started a scholarship in her name
in less than two years they've awarded
over 57
hundred dollars to nine former gregson
elementary students
it's comforting in a way because you
truly see
like she lives on through
through all this maria jose may be gone
but her
impact will always live on we will do
all that we can
to support them all the way through
college so that they can achieve their
dreams
and those who loved her say this work is
a way to show
everyone where her heart will always be
you're helping people even though you're
not here you're helping people and
i hope she knows that
now the scholarship fund is still
accepting donations
maria jose's friends and family have
also held multiple virtual and in-person
fundraising events they
have also started a special clothing
line all to raise money for the cause
if you'd like to help would like more
information on any of those
we have that on our website eight
newsnow dot com
reporting live sasha loftis 8 news now